>> JACKEY GET THE START FOR THE
BLUE JACKETS AND BRAD LARSSON
GETS DANGEROUS, HIS FIRST TO KEG
THESTS
IT RIGHT THERE AS HE ATTACKED
TO REACT YOU
CAN SEE HE WAS STILL IN THE
MOLUES GET IT RIGHT GOAL.
PATRICK LAINE FEEDING NYQUIST.
WHAT A
AND THAT'S HOWOWTTY FEED AND LAE
WITH HIS SECOND POINT AND THE T.
PATRICK LAINE, THE A SHOT STRAM.
JACKETS DEEP IN THE ZONE, PEEKE
LONG.O
CENTERING PASS ACROSS THE LINE..
>> HIS FIRST N AND
IT'S SEEMS TO
THE FROM POINT BLANK RAN CONTINH
GOAL OF
TAKE,.  OFF THE
POST AND IN IT'S A ONENE POSITI.
YOU'RE GOING TO GIVE UP DAY
NOW THE JACKETS ARE BACK IN THE.
HUSSO SHOT, AND HUSSO GOT
JUST ENOUGH OF IT TO SEND IT
COMPLETES THE HAT TRICK AND IT'S
A ONE-GOAL GAM
INSIDE AND KORPISALO